each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available it's my pleasure to present go
Wong here who is going to give a talk
about probabilistic special modeling of
reverberant audio applied to Source
separation uh he took his bachelor's
degree in his native Vietnam took his
master's degree in career and is going
to finish his PhD in indri and France so
it's a long and interesting part of
doing research most of it in the area of
audio signal processing so without
further Ado we have the floor okay yes
thank you for the introduction and uh
good morning everyone so uh first I
briefly again tell a bit about my bik
Rous
I'm I'm a vietnames so uh for 4 and a
half years I took a bachelor degrees in
electrical engineering in post and
telecommunication Institute in Vietnam
and then I have almost one and a half
years working as a system engineer in
Industries mainly for the polycom uh
video conference products like audio and
S Visual and then I for two years I
moved to the ker s career to uh pursue
the master degrees Al also in electrical
engineering and mainly focus on Signal
processing and after getting the degrees
I had a half years working as a research
uh engineer in the Imes company also
that companies focus on sound and speed
technology which transfer to to the more
Big Industry and then after finish uh
not really finished but then I get the
funding for the PSD and then uh I moved
to France this is a France national
Research Institute in computer SCI and
cono it's IND uh to pursue my
phsd up to now and Myan can be in
October this year so in four four months
so it's exactly 3 years PhD okay that is
a in my
background okay so today is I'm very
happy to present my uh PSD work uh
probability space model for re reun and
diffuse sources appli to audio Source
separation okay so please feel free to
interrupt me at any times for your
question or
comments okay here we goes the problem
we are looking at is uh in a C party
effects where we have many s sources
mixed together uh in a meeting room for
instance or in a party room which
prevent people from understanding for
instance here is a real recording in a
meeting room I recorded in India
everyone I'm
glading
the okay he's a voice of director of
India so you feel that is very difficult
to
understand and especially for the
acoustic uh for the a recognizer to
recognize the talk with a lot of B noise
uh and interference like
that so our goal is to separate the
sources from the recorded signal which
is mixure uh and this problem is known
as a bland short separation it's a BS
and Bs has a lots of practical
application for instance for hearing
system uh for Speed recognition which is
very familiar with you and also for like
robotic or music information retriever
uh in this community where people try to
separate uh uh the different component
like r or harmonies or pie component to
do some uh music information reer
task so uh considering uh the recording
environment uh we uh in reality we have
two types of environment one is an and
the other one is re or what are they the
an environment come from the perfect
Studio like this or in the outdoor
recording where the rever uh environment
come from a meeting room or the shamber
for if you uh record mixure in anck
environment you will hear quite clear
sound like this among them are canvases
by a young artist building from the
ground up is very costly next year we'll
see several more
exhibitions male and female voice you
can but if you do the same things in a
shamber with a lot of revation what you
will hear is this
among building from the
ground next year we see
several hear a lot of Echo and you feel
that this one is actually very difficult
to
processes and why you have Sky of
differences uh because in the anate
environment you only record the Rel s
pass from the source to the microphone
without any reflection while in the uh
reversion room you have a lot of s
Reflection from the sauce to the
microphone so this is a nice picture
from the cafeteria of in of
India so as you hear the sou and uh you
see from here it's very difficult to
model exactly the acoustic path from the
source to the the microphone in inner
reversion environment and the source
separation here remain very challenging
why state of z uh uh approach provide
already some good results in case of
anate
environment that's why in my PhD work I
focus more on uh the modeling of re
ration environment which have Target
more a practical
application
okay now if we look at some state of Z
General approach there's two kind of
information we can exploit the first one
is to model and explore the spal
information that is looking at the spal
position and location of the sources and
another one is to motel and exploit the
spectral cues which is more related to
the spectal information of the sources
more detail uh what are they uh spal
simp one of spal cues you can imagine is
a ph and int dity differences for
instance uh you look at the inate
recording environment and if the S is
here which is closer to the microphone
is1 so the recording signal i1 will be
larger than I2 so we have a very simple
uh proportional uh amplitude between i1
and I2 like that but if the source move
to the poison B which is closer to the
microphone I one so we have uh uh the
spal Q now is a blue one B so uh that I2
is is is a l than S1 so this is very
simple give you the basic ID of the spal
cues and for the spal cues uh you can
exploit for instance like if you look at
the spe of speed it can be explo the
harmonicity uh the smoothness for
instance the Spectrum here is very
smooth over the uh frequency R and it is
spacity because here a lot of time
physic SE Point uh
coefficient is close to
zero and uh we look at a state of Z
approach for sour separation we found
that there is much work on spectal cues
that is based on statistical model like
GMM hmm or uh non- negative Mage
factorization for instance and there is
actually very Le to work on spal cues
and most of them based on the
deterministic model for instance in the
an recording and they deterministic CLE
Mod The Source po by the face and
intensity differences which are far from
the actual uh characteristic of the reor
environment and also for the diffus
background noise where you cannot mot
deterministically uh the spal
information of the
sources so uh for our PSD uh looking at
that problem we have uh switch uh from
the deterministic model to probabili
model framework for spal cues that is
our main contribution and then we design
a general uh architecture for model
parameter
estimation uh and Source
separation and then uh we uh propose uh
several uh probabilities prior over the
spal PO of the sources or the spal
information of the sources uh and
demonrat the post of the propose
framework in various uh uh practical
setting which I will show later on in in
the simulation but here
summarize uh of the contribution and I I
I I will address all this problem later
on okay so given that very general ideas
and overview so here will be the
contents of my presentation uh in the
next part I will focus on the general uh
Frameworks and parameterization where I
present our propos general aan modeling
framework the spal covariant
parameterization and the sof separation
architecture design for a general
case and then in the next part I move to
uh the center of the problem is how to
estimate the model parameter right we
have framework we have a
parameterization
but it's very important that we we must
estimate the modal parameter in order to
perform our work and then I can present
several uh probabilities prior in order
to have enhance s separation and finally
I we come with some
conclusion
okay okay so now we look at the problem
in a more mathematic way uh we have to
formulate it right so if a you have
original sources uh uh let's denote by h
of Z where Z is a source indexes in a in
a party room and what you observes as a
microphone is not SJ itself right it is
a recorded signal called a CJ uh and CI
is called Source Imes it means that it's
a contribution of the sources as the
microphone and the purpose of SCE
separation is that given uh the observe
mixture here you need to estimate uh uh
the source Imes
CJ and since uh we have a mixure of
several sources so what you uh really
observe as a microphone already is a
mixure is called s of T is a i by1
Vector where I is number of microphone
and HD will be the sum of
CJ uh Z over one to the total number of
sources okay so now so propose is given
XJ you estimate the C
e okay so let me emphasize that we are
not targeting estimating the original
sources but we try to estimate the
source
Imes okay so a first state of just
modeling framework most of course use a
deterministic model for space c which
realiz on the two main assumption the
first assumption people make is a PO
Source assumption
where uh where the acoustic pass from
The Source microphone is model by the
missing Vector h of Z so what you You
observe at the microphone CJ will be the
convolution of the original sources with
uh the missing Vector S Sub
J and then here is a convolution in time
domain and if you assume that uh the
window L is much larger than uh uh the
actual f l of SJ you have a narrow
approximation where the convolution in
time domain is approximated by the uh
complex value multiplication in the
frequency domain so given those two
Basics assumption uh most set of a for
view their s separation uh uh
system so we see that in practice uh
this two equation D not house due to a
couple of reason for instance due to the
nonstationary of SJ so for instance when
I talk I'm not uh straight forward as
this sometime I move sometime I move
ahead so you cannot M by a deterministic
or fix missing Vector H ofj and also
because of diffuse reation or diffuse s
you have a very diffus very lot of
reation so modeling by a sing missing
Vector may not uh in so for that reason
uh we switch to a probabilistic uh
framework and here it
is so in uh our purpose framework uh we
uh propose to
model The Source IM CJ as a zero mean
Gan random variable with the covariant
magic is uh Sigma okay and here is a for
of probability uh uh function for gaan
is
simple uh let me uh emphasize a bit why
we use gaussian modeling here for
instance in s separation uh many people
use lab lation distribution for the
sources or something but instead of that
we use Goan here just couple of Reason
uh for last uh because first we if we
consider the physical acoustic so the
ration is generary model astion is in
the acoustic point of view and it is
easy to handle the computation so if
later on I we so with the Goan modeling
we result in a close form update for the
parameter estimation which is good and
okay we s that of course it work so this
is very important Point
okay so furthermore uh now what you have
is this one this is uh you have zero Min
already and you have unknown covariant
Sigma and furthermore in our framework
we factorize Sigma Z by the product of
two parameter VJ and AJ where uh VJ uh
is a Time varying Source uh variances
which can incode the spal temporal power
of the sources so if you switch and take
some time frequency point so V been
modeling the uh spectal temporal power
and a is actually we call it a spal
covariant matrixes with GRE incode the
spal information of the sources what we
refer to spal information it will
include the special the spal info the
spal direction of the sources and the
reversion uh in the room so all the
spatial information of the tosis is in
ined here and all the spectral
information of the sources for instance
it can be model by gnm SNM or something
is encoded by V so you separate by two
component and all of Z is encoded in the
space of coal in in a coent mat
Sigma can you go back to the previous
slide okay yeah so the dimension of the
vector here is just frequency a vector
here C I mean you have n and F when you
at variance Matrix you're looking at
frequency is the dimension of the Matrix
uh no the dimension of the Matrix
isn't is is a number of microphone so if
you have two microphone you have 2X two
Matrix okay okay so you have a c here is
a vector of the let's say I have I
microphone so C is a vector of I by one
right so you have one source here what
You observe at the I microphone is a
vector I by one so we
that all frequencies are one frequency
is independent of the next one the
adjacent one
right uh no not really so here we we
model for each time frequency Point
independently right so that's what I'm
saying making the assumption that what
happens at this frequency at the next
frequency it's
independent are separated for each
frequency B and not related to each
other yeah yeah sure that is a general
assumption but later on when I come back
I will make a less switch assumption
where I can assume some dep dependencies
between time fency point but at this at
this time for General framework Let Me
Assume first that it is independent and
let me m first for each time frequency
Point by this one
okay so again uh V will be the scalar
and R will be I by I a square message
right where I is number microphone so if
you have St case you have a 2 x two
microphone for each time frequency point
and for each sources
Jo is that clear or something
okay okay and in most of the following
uh we more assume that uh a is time
invariant so we will not have a time
here the reason we we assume that is uh
for inst now uh we don't deal with some
very challenging case for the moving
source so we assume small Source
movement lies or F poison so we assume
that as modeling the spal information is
time invariant but also let me come back
to time variant case later in my
presentation but at this point okay uh
for
that so this assumption is also made by
most state of Z approach where the spal
location of the sources is model by the
missing vector which is the time
invariance
okay okay let me uh show you here for
instance there also more the space of
information by Time invariant s depend
on app so now we make the same
things like this
one
okay
so now as as I uh said before uh our
work is mainly focused on modeling the
spal cues it means that we focus on the
modeling for a which is our focus and in
the next slide I will present the
parameterization for
a uh okay so uh now again look at the
state of approach for
a in the an recording where there's no
reation so a can be computed directly
from the missing
Vector
right so uh for instance uh if uh in the
an missing environment if you know the
source and the microphone position so
the knowledge from the room acoustic
will allow you to compute directly the
mixing Vector from the source to the
microphone like this where an here is I
I refer to the an missing environment so
if you compute as analy this one so the
covariant magic IJ can be
computed uh like a product of uh S and S
heran that is the simpl SK of the an and
why I refer to the rank one here because
this is a product of two Vector so the
Mage is rank one matage
right okay uh if you look at uh the uh
popular parameterization based on the
narrow band appr information I present
before it means that we have a CJ
approximated by the product of AJ and
the original sources so now if you
compute the coent matri of CJ so you
have Sigma Z will be the expectation of
CJ and C8 and you will result in this
form why this PA
is scalar and is a Visa it includes the
special tempor special temporal
information of the sources and the spal
covariant matage AJ can be computed by
SJ sjs and again it can be the rank one
matches right so what I say in this
slide is that whatever you consider the
anage uh recording environment or uh
rever environment this set of Z
parameterization for AJ is the rank one
Matrix in both
Cas
okay so what we do is that we don't want
the rank one Matrix we want more full
rank matri with uh provide more a free
parameter to better model the viberation
so we look at uh what we call here is a
full rank R plus refuse parameterization
where we exploit the knowledge from the
theory of room
acoustic okay this model is sply new
because it is uh consider it was
considered in the context of s
localization before but this is the
first time we look at it in the context
of s
separation okay so if you assume that
the re pass from the source to the
microphone and the reation is is
uncorrelated so the variant green be the
sum of the co variant of the r path
which is computed by here right by the
mixing vector and the covariant of the
diffuse reation
path okay so yeah the the underlying
assumption is that the re part and the
re PA is
unated where sray of an is computed
before so if you look at state of Z so
state of Z modeling is this one so now
we look at a full rank parameterization
where we add here some contribution of
the
reation okay I have a question here
about your I mean like if you go back to
the previous slide like so so clearly in
the lower equation right some of the
your channel characteristics are now
being captured in the co Varian only an
expectation right like you're basically
taking Statistics over the expectation
of the in product now that's going to
lose something right it's not the entire
actual Channel characteris some
expectation some characteristics that
captur expectations my question is that
when you go to the next slide and you're
saying that like okay well now we're
going to open up this Matrix to be full
rank Coan Matrix to be full rank um do
you have some intuitions behind why
covariance is a good means of capturing
the reation channel characteristics
because it's not 100% right some it's
capturing it in expectation what do you
lose what do you gain in that
representation okay so uh yeah what I
said before is that uh for state of most
most approach like deterministic model
for spal information by the missing
Vector so if we you apply directly s
kind of deterministic model in our
framework so for goian modeling
framework this one it is our our our
propos modeling framework and if you
bring directly the state of uh
parameterization yeah so get the right
understand but I get that but what I'm
saying is that like you know here you're
saying that you're going to expand that
by using full rank right but there's
still this question of you know why is
the karian structure the right way to
represent reverberation is there enough
information there in the variant to
really tell you about what the per
channels I guess the question is is it
still gaussian or not yeah if it is then
that's probably fine if it is but maybe
it isn't me I'm also wondering about
like you know what's being lost when you
turn this into an expectation quantity
over over but if it is G then that
you're just maybe you should not be
adding that term maybe it's some other
combination but right but it may not be
GOI yes we don't know
yes uh okay I will demo I I as I
understand you your question is why we
need the full L and why we need to ask
more uh parameterization in the Coan
message that's not really my question
but it's okay I can ask you later kid
sorry
mhm I'm really so I'll just say it again
but you don't need to necessarily answer
right now maybe it'll become clear in
your talk the question is more saying is
that is the gaan a good way I mean is
the gaan approximation a good
approximation for what's actually
happening okay yeah I would not Sayan
it's the best way it's a good way but uh
yeah as I thought have several reason
why we consider Rian in prever slide of
course you can consider another ones for
inance LA or something but uh it may
more difficult for you to estimate
parameter later on or something oh I I
have death do this I point is like if it
turns out that it's not for a gaussian
then adding more parameters to a gaan
representation won't necessarily help
you but if you have a strong argument
for why it is Gan okay okay
yeah but for sure that for physical
acoustic if you look at the acoustic
book where most people in physical
acoustic community we model the
reversion as aian I mean not modeling
both as aian I mean if you consider the
pass so it's okay not gaan but for
theuse reversion path so the really
motor is is a gaan so yeah that is one
of the reason we consider there is a
stage of distinct Reflections from the
walls when the speech signal to
distribution basically moves from The
Sharper plus towards more and more and
more gaan and as the tail of the end is
completely Gan it's a sum of pretty much
infinite number of Reflections see but
there is a some period between the
direct part and the tail when kind of
gradually goes from the sharper
distribution and this is what actually
is missing there right
yeah sorry for that for example if you
look at the modeling for the original s
itself for the S uh for for okay let me
come back this one if you look at the
modeling for the S itself here it's
obious not Goan right it's more like
laptop or something but now we looking
at the modeling for it's image to the
microphone so there's a lot of pration
so there should be some less sharper as
a
evaluation okay
thanks
okay
okay yes now we stop here and this uh
this model have been considered in the
context of source localization uh in
2003 for for for the first paper I saw
yeah but
now uh we bring this one in the Contex
of s look separation and we see how it
perform in in in in in this contest so
the second Matrix yeah oh sorry okay
so yeah if this assumption is satisfied
and if you know the geometry setting you
know everything so the knowledge from
the room acoustic will allow you to
compute uh Omega and sigma directly from
the room acoustic for instance if the
room is rectangular if you know the
reflection coefficient it means that you
will know the revering time and you know
the area something so you compute uh the
proportion between the reversion and the
res part and it's very nice that uh this
uh coant matage here is a kind of sync
function so yeah it is proved already so
it's is kind of deterministic if you
know everything you have this
model okay so the second the the Omega
think is derived in 1954 paper I can
find it I believe where do you get the
the second the the second uh yeah one
yeah is is also from the textbook
of yeah it's a very uh old textbook like
60s or something it's gr
already and this equation is also
written my mistake I should mention some
refence here in
m f in informing I I think
theer the second one okay thank you yeah
yeah I remember M also use this model
for
true but that's in earlier paper 1954 is
is the publication of that s x under X
dependence of the coverance Matrix yeah
yeah but uses it yes yeah that's why I
say it's not really new but it's new in
the context of such separation that I I
consider here okay but Z is actually is
not what I want I just move from the the
rank one to the one I I want so what I
really want is that I here you see that
it is full rank but it is too much
constraint it is you have to know
everything and it's contribution of Z
spark and contribution this spark is is
too much constraint and what we want is
that we want to relax all the constraint
and we want to uh present a as really a
full R
mates okay so what is look
like if you consider state of Z rank one
whether rank one an or rank one
convolutive it
the coant the spal coant magic is a
product of two Vector so it's a r one
magic so what I propose in my work is
that we propose to PR a as arbitary
hermit Matrix where we release all the
constraints so you see yeah there over
three slide this one is too much
constraint it is a less constraint we
ask more and this one is is what we
propose here it's really unconcern so we
have more parameter to model the ration
okay okay so now uh we already have a uh
Gan modeling framework we have
parameterization for the spal coent
mates and it's time to design the S
separation
architecture okay now look at it you
have observe which I subt you transform
into time frequency domain you have I
sub NF
given the Goan modeling framework so the
parameter you need to estimate is the
source variances for each sources and
the special coent matches for each
sources J and once you estimate this one
you can perform winner multi Channel
winner filtering to estimate uh uh C J
and then you uh converts back to time
domain to get uh what we want okay for
multi chel winner filtering uh okay we
have equation here if you know VJ and
AJ for all time frequency point for all
sources
right so you okay so this simply an
equation but here uh let me emphasize
that here we assume that the sources is
uncorrelated so we have a corant matrix
of X is the sum of the coent matri of
each sources Okay so this is
uncorrelated assumption Which is less uh
than the
independencies so Z spark Z spark and Z
SP is ready what we want now is this
about how we estimate the VJ and
AJ okay going be our
Focus okay but uh before uh actually
estimating this parameter let me first
demonstrate the potential of of of the
propos framework in uh in in uh in the
Oracle setting and semi Bland setting
for instance in the Oracle parameter
estimation all the parameter here is
estimated from the known s image so uh
it mean that this Z que provide the
upper BS on the S separation performance
right if you know everything so and you
can compute parameter it will show you
the upper B so I I just want to improve
to prove that the upper bow and short
separation of the propose framework is
higher than the upper bow of the
performance of the state of Z appro so
if we succeed in this way so later on we
will manage to estimate the parameter
blly from the mixure so that is the
purpose of this
work and in the semi Bland we call Semi
Bland parameterization this means that
we estimate the spatial parameter from
the known source Imes but we blend
estimate the source variances from the
mixure okay so I will skip the detail I
present later on but this parameter is
estimate in the maximum laih sh using em
is expectation maximization aism and we
evaluate uh the performance the S
separation performance using the
wellknown
criteria like signal to Distortion SDR
and signal to interference Ratio or
something think uh do you are familiar
with this ination me between signal to
Distortion ratio and signal
to okay so uh okay so for this theories
of uh
criteria uh if you have the estimated
signal so it say that the estimated
signal can be factorized by the sum of
several component so you have estimated
signal can be the sum of the original
signal plus some artifact plus the
interference from another
sources right so we have several
component so the signal to interference
ratio will measure the ratio between the
the the choose Source signal and the the
contribution of of of another sources
which is in the
factorization and uh signal to
Distortion Rao we measure r the overall
Distortion so it's the ratio of the Good
original sources to all the another
Distortion and the signal to artifact we
measure The Rao between the signal and
artifact in and the musical noise for
instance yeah so you see that the SDR
will measure the overall performance of
the system why this SP will measure the
specific uh application so you're trying
to estimate the actual signal or a
filter version of the signal a filter
version of signal
yeah I have a question about the number
of parameters here so so there's like so
for the ciance matrix it's full Rank and
fully anra so it's n^ s/ two parameters
for each ciance Matrix right and then
you have that for separately for each
frequency to add okay yeah okay I get I
I I will provide the number later on in
my slide okay thank you for
that okay yeah so I just say easy to uh
uh well known so here is the results in
two case uh Z is average for 10 uh speed
mixure of three sources with the
different Dua and the microphone spacing
we use is 20 cm and the distance from
the sour to microphone is 1.2
M and we compare the results of ourpose
full rang uncon
parameterization with the full direct
plus def it's a parly new as I before
and we compare with state of Z rank one
convolutive and rank one an model and we
also compare with the two Baseline
approach this is well known it's called
binary masking and aor
minimization and here is the results we
have uh regarding your question about
the number of parameter so of course you
see for the F and con you have much more
parameter than another one right because
you have a three parameter for for each
uh sources at each time frequency point
so if you multiply by the number of time
frequency point and you multiply by the
number of soures three you get this
total number of parameter need to be
estimate uh for rank one convolutive
which is uh mostly used they have a half
a parameter because it's rank one so has
only two and it's it's very interesting
that for rank one direct place you have
a very ler parameter rank one we have it
would be the square root right I mean
this is think the three the 3,000 is
that coming from the filter length of
the conative uh the estimation of the of
the conative filter because I mean if
you have a rank one Matrix versus a full
rank Matrix has the square root the
number of parameters right not
half uh rank one is just you know vector
vector okay and now
you so when you on is that the is that
the number of filter Taps that you're
estimating for the filter response or
why is it so large no no okay for
instance here I use
12,24 uh tests for the fer okay so uh we
need to estimate a positive uh half of
that right so it's should be
5 13 it's a number of frequency band
okay right so we multiply
53 with the three sources multiply by
three okay and is is two ster case you
have have a two uh 2x one vector for
each mixing matage so it's 513 MTI by
three mtip by two and you get this
number okay and for the full rank you
get dou how many microphones two
microphone I use ter okay so is this a
real recording or it's
simulated uh it is simulated yeah in
using image method yeah yeah IM what is
the rt60 of the room simulator uh it is
uh 200 uh 50 okay yeah is 3 so what is
the sampling rate for this it's a 16 khz
so how long of a reverberation can you
handle with 1,000
tabs uh assuming you know the limitation
of you know the product uh okay so for
16,000 and now you have only uh one uh
1,000 deps so it is like one one
yeah 16 87 Mills yeah much less than
25 so pretty much your model pass to the
moment the reverberation goes down
around
20b and that's kind of explains
especially the best numbers
there oh okay again so I L something so
if you have we we have 16 uh 16
KZ frames it's a 116 of a second which
is 87 86. 66 milliseconds this is
roughly 13 of your R6 which which is
when the reverberation goes down to -
60b pretty much
you're taking a span of the
reverberation when it goes down to minus
20 that is our purpose because we need
to take the very short uh fter compared
to the actual Rion if you take it longer
there there should be no meaning right
so it is okay then you have a lot more
problems yeah yeah okay I I I
guess I have some understanding here
anymore okay so yeah here is the results
for Oracle for Oracle of course you have
a much larger number because everything
is estimated from the known s Imes and
the sear performance is decre in a Shamy
blend but overall you can see that's uh
the proper uncon outperform or another
uh in yeah please so you said that your
metrices were number of microphones my
number of microphones so here they're
just 2 by two yeah right so then your
then you're um then the explosion
parameters is very small because n squ
is just four right like you know it's
supposed to like at 10 likes okay you
know so so I wonder you know so so uh
I'm just wondering um because so so
could you actually break down the 4617
where the uh where those parameters are
coming from where the four where the 4,7
parameters are coming from for the full
rank case a four four mic Cas yeah for
the for the no no no no no just for just
for your case just I just want to know
the breakdown of
4,617 okay in terms of where those
parameters are coming from in terms of a
spal parameter no just what the what are
the 4 cuz you broke it down for the rank
one convolutive one you say 52 tabs
times okay so so you want this
case so for this one we also have a
513 frequency band okay and you also
have a three sources okay let me
emphasize that we are focusing on the
under determined case where we use a
smaller number of microphone to separate
larger number of sources which is much
more challenging yeah okay so that's why
I use terl for three sources okay so
let's come back you have 513 you
multiply by three and you multiply by
four for is the point yeah so you have
that yeah but what we really uh happy
and uh surprising is that for this model
with a very little parameter but it pro
provide quite good uh results it's a bit
less than uh the set of that here but it
use very little let me explain why it is
it for instance if you look at here so
what you need to know is that
uh microphone spacing is one parameter
and you need to know the distance from
the source to the microphone so if you
have two microphone and three sources
you have six
parameter right so you have six
parameter for the distance and
microphone spacing is uh is is seven and
then you need to know a bit about
reversion time and that's it so are you
estimating the room parameters as well
in in those figures no for that I Ed I I
I I I assume that it is known yeah but
you could estimate those in princi that
is one of the feuture work I I would
mention yeah it would be nice if we can
estimate s Sky parameter and incorporate
yeah but at this time okay let me first
go assume that we
know so actually if you look at the
upper table the full brand canra the
full run Direct by diff fuse are fairly
close it's only when you do the
estimation yeah yeah yeah that all of
them yeah that is really amazing it it
means that if we know exactly everything
so this model is is quite good to to to
to to handle the reation PA yeah I mean
even even before you maybe you know do
this future work of of trying to
estimate those it might be interesting
just to see what the sensitivity of
those results would be with respect to
small preservations in the room estiment
because if it's robust to
to I see what you mean when I presented
some conference some people ask me about
the variation about that is quite yeah
but for for the short time of my thesis
I actually this I haven't got much time
to investigate this one I more
investigate this one because in France
we get almost two and a half years for
doing a research and a half year to
write thesis so actually for we I have
only two years to do this is shorter
than in us but yeah you right okay let
me continue something so now I prove
that uh for the upper B on the S
separation you have good performance so
let's move to the real uh parameter
going to hear some sounds there
okay
nice because we have like 15 minutes
more okay yeah nice okay here is is just
one specific case I did long time before
but recently I did I write my thesis so
I test on a very last later base and we
get a very similar ones with a different
microphone s to microphone distance
different duration time and I raw
function and so I get okay for instance
you have
m
okay that is three sauces and for the r
one one among them are canvases by a
young artist building from the ground up
is
very okay and in our case you hear among
them are canvases by a young artist
building from the ground is
very okay again among them are canvases
by a young artist building from the
very okay yeah you have
more
buing so in in you have lots of musical
noise right that is artifact that's why
we use S A R for you have more is
musical noise yeah so in the Oracle
results above what you what you mean by
Oracle is just the geometry right oh
yeah it means that we know everything we
know the SCE know the whole signals we
know the whole signal yeah for our yeah
if you know the whole
signals the of the performance it give
the uper B the performance I I know the
whole
s okay that's why I I I don't want to
play sell here because I know everything
so there's no words to play the perfect
sell here yeah but I just want to prove
if the parameter is estimated from the
very good I mean it's is no so back and
in the lower case the geometry is known
but not the source images right yeah
yeah okay so now I question about this
the
um
your uh figures of Merit did they depend
on frequency as well yeah it seemed like
for the full rank un constrain most of
the signal to the most of the
interference was low frequency yeah that
there wasn't a lot of leakage from high
frequency from the
other uh uh the other sources mhm is
that why why would it first of all is
that truly happening and why would that
what what's causing that why would the
low
frequency leak more than the high
frequencies from the interfering
sources of course for the for for Speed
sources most the energy of the sources
will lie in in a low frequency right so
course in the low frequency range you
have more interference I mean you can
you can hear more
interference because actually in the
mixure itself it will have more energy
Li in a low frequency range right and in
terms of uh mathematic things I don't
see the differences in my uh
framework the differen is between the
low and the high because we treat the
low and the high
equally and we apply the same uh
parameter estimation for the old
frequency be the interfering sounds for
when you played the full rank
unconstrained weren't a low volume male
speech it was a muffled nail speech
where the low frequencies were leaking
through
mhm and so you you haven't looked into
what could be causing that in your
framework
or yes I actually I I I I didn't really
look closely inside the speed uh uh a
spectrum feature
I that really affect uh the speed uh
recognition system or something yeah
okay okay yes thank you for that I look
at more or maybe it is just one specific
case because we have three sources and I
play only one sources when you hear
another source maybe differences or
maybe different sources I don't know
yeah but to be Hest I I feel the equally
CH yeah I guess yeah similar but I mean
like you know I mean how much is this
dependent on the maybe you just haven't
done this analysis but like you know
particular
spacing you know it's going to make some
differences there right like you know I
mean you're going to you're not going to
have the same estimation capabilities
for different frequencies given a
particular aperture okay you're going to
have I that might be where limitations
are coming from either that or the frame
length the yeah ex okay for for that
frequency resolution let me uh present
it next slide because I also have some
work on uh on the frequency resolution
where instead of trying a shortterm F
transform which provides a linear uh
resolution I use some more like
acoustically motivated uh representation
we provide more resolution at the low
frequency range so I will present later
on in this work okay so let me
move okay so now we move to the next
part where uh I present the general
framework to estimate the parameter from
the
Mi okay here is your
structure I choose uh expectation
maximization Em which is well known for
the Rian M model and for em you may know
that it's very sensitive to the
initialization so we need to desire a
good parameter initialization
scheme and in the maximum likelihood
sense since we estimate the parameter
independently in each frequency be so
there may be some permutation problem in
the frequency domain so later on we need
to solve the permutation problem
okay so what is news in in in this
framework is
that in most signal processing approach
so the input for the parameter
estimation is observe M signal I but in
our case we consider the input by the
empirical Mi covariant uh Sigma of i
instead of the signal itself so I also
will explain this one later but now here
we have several block this for the Bland
parameter
estimation and we also consider the
parameter estimation in the maximum
poster sense uh where okay is a mathc
term and in this case if we have some
prior knowledge about the parameter so
we can estimate the parameter jly iny be
so we don't need to show permutation
problem after okay so Z General BL and
in the following I will present a bit
detail in each step and for these two
step uh I just exploit the existing
measur which is not uh our main
contribution and our main work we focus
on these three part
okay so here is the parameter of uh
initialization uh I mainly designed
relying on the work of WI
present in rece COD where we uh Choice
hierarchical clustering of the mixure as
uh at e frequency be uh after some phase
and amplitude normalization so for the
source of time let me uh uh skip this
slide because uh it is not our main
contribution and it's just for parameter
initialization okay I explain more about
the empirical uh mure Co variant uh why
we use input is a sigma head of X
instead of the signal
itself
so okay ideally we need to estimate VJ
and RJ using uh this relation Sigma X
but in practice Sigma I is not observed
what we really observe is empirical Mi
Co variant Sigma hat of I and we compute
Sigma I of hat as the
average over the neighboring frequency
Point like this
one so and this one can be interpreted
as a so quadratic transform later on I
been present results with the uh
equivalent rectangular BWI this is more
acoustically motivated time frequency
representation and why we uh want to
estimate parameter from Sigma inste of
the signal itself because compared to I
so Sigma I will provide add information
about the interal coefficient and it
will take into account the neighboring
frequency as you mentioned before so we
slightly relies on the neighboring
frequency
Point okay so you're you're you're
mixing between neighboring channels and
neighboring mics here in the you're
saying no not not chn but uh time
frequency reason only no I understand
but oh just time frequency re
M okay so this is time and and this is
frequency so you get the same frequency
being back and one more back the
previous frame you get plus the two
neigh frequencies yeah yeah I mean z is
General case if you set the L of w is
two so we have 2 by two and I test
several case with different length of w
and I find 2 by two lies provide the
best performance so it's okay and uh
this one is the main point and this one
we contribute half of that so you have a
shape of fer
okay okay and here's a general uh
expectation maximization algorism it
include the Eep and M step and in Eep we
try to estimate the multi Channel winner
F and the estimated Co variant for each
sources Sig J okay I will skip the
detail and for M step the parameter is
iteratively update like this one VJ and
so update of V will depend on a and
update a will depend on V this is in the
maximum
likely and in the maximum poster recent
V andj can be estimated by the cost
function including the contribution of
the likelihood and the contribution of
the prior which I will present later on
where I introduce some trail parameter
to uh take into account estimate both
the V and vs simultaneously yeah yeah
because we don't know uh these two
parameter right yeah from the same
amount of data yeah from same because
the V the you could learn with a lot
more data you don't to specialize it
right yeah yeah I see there's many of
course learn Vis but uh to learn Visa
you need to know I mean the training
data should be close to the the isolator
right but for instance in short
separation context in general case when
some people go into a room and talk so
you don't really have training data and
also in state of z uh many model for
Visa is present like you can present
Visa at the nmf model or as a mi of
San and they will train uh the the ran
which model to get the estimation of
V but here because my framework is
focused on AJ so we assume that there is
no PRI information on VJ but VJ is a
function of N and F so it's like a ton
of parameters right mhm and as long as
the the trans length yeah I mean if you
do not put any prior information yes you
have standard parameter but if you put
some model for visa for instance in MF
mot so we have a Visa would be uh some
activation and some patent some some
beam pattern for instance so you have
less
parameter is this are you doing this
optimization separately per frame or is
this yeah it is doing
separate for it sources at its frequency
but but not each frame you're doing this
tied across the entire input yeah
because you see here uh a will be sum of
O frame for V
yeah okay is that
okay yes so for permutation problem uh
let me skip also because uh I just
reproduce the work of sa in ntity group
in Japan where he exploit uh the Dua
direct uh the source direction to Sol
permutation
problem okay so here is some results we
get so this is the actual results we
also average SDR which measures overall
Distortion over 10 simulated speed
mixure
so we uh compare the result of the full
rank uncon with the rank one convolutive
case and the Baseline of frost is By REM
masking and our minimization because we
at this time we don't take into account
another model like f r plus because we
already proved that uh it provide lower
upper B performance so at this St of the
res I only consider the full R
unconcern and here is the result for
very low reation time of 50 millisecond
so you will see that for low reation
time the rank one convolutive and the F
rang provide approximately the same
result because re is very low but as far
as we move to the high higher River
rated room so our purpose
parameterization will clearly
outperform z b Sloss and state of yes is
this still the semiblind scenario where
you know Source location no Z is really
uh it's really blind blind are they
static Source locations or are they
moving Source uh Source location is it's
fixed but we don't know
yeah for instance uh yeah now you hear
the sound in 250
millisecond building from
so for
R this F's too spicy he complained young
men can be very arrogant and rude so
Marcus owned a big
shipping
for this's too spicy to complain young
men can be very arrogant and Ro Marcus
owned a big shipping company so I
thought i' heard results for the rang
onean convoluted mixtures that sound
better than this in terms other research
researchers uh in terms of interference
or artifi or overall you overall okay we
can hear again
right too spicy he complained young men
can be very arrogant and rude so Marcus
owned a big shipping
comp my recollection of some conference
here I mean it's maybe they weren't in a
river bre room or that's probably the
biggest difference yes so depends on how
rever go back one second so what level
of reverberation were you showing those
sound samples that uh 2 I'm sorry
250 okay so maybe that's the difference
yes possible no but even for this one I
gu in many cases the full R clearly
better I don't know no I'm saying that
what I've heard in other conferences the
separation was much better but perhaps
it was much less vibration maybe ah okay
okay yeah yeah CU there it looks like
they're almost the same yeah in low
reation time it's almost the same or
something but uh as I said before our
res is targeting desire for the rated
environment that with low reparation
times you do as well as yeah or even
recently I test when writing a thesis I
test a larger number of data set with a
different scenario so I so at the time I
observe that even the WR one perform
better at at the low reation
my recollection it was even better than
10 DB maybe 50 milliseconds it was
better than 10 DB that's my recollection
M SL I'm sorry 70 Mond
SL this is what they used for when they
publish their like the guys from ATR
like what the demos that I listen to to
me the some better than 10 DB some I
know that the preparation is short 12
really did you use headphones when you
listen to them or was it a talk like
this I have try
both okay so Z this one case I I I have
a kind of question for the room was it
I'm not familiar with the data you're
using for this yeah and to me both
examples sounded unintelligible
mhm I was maybe able to pick out two or
three words from either the rank one
convolutive or the full rank constraint
mhm is that so it doesn't really seem
like the difference is useful at
250 is it is this the biggest difference
that you see with this technique or are
we going to see better
results yes if you look at the number
you you you see differences but here as
I mentioned as a play one specific case
so so here I see 2 DB difference at 250
milliseconds uh so qu like 1 DB or
something 1 DB quantitatively they're
different but qualitatively I found them
to both be
unintelligible okay you have uh some
experiments that show there's
some uh domain where you use this
technique and there's qualitative
results that are positive okay I saw it
later on will okay let me emphasize that
in in a s station Community 1db SD is is
really last Improvement if you look at
the performance year after year so you
see that it's approach is like 1.3 or
1.5 SD or something performance so it's
not easy to get like One DB this is a
significant change yeah yeah let me
emphasize that this is really a
significant chance and in this slide I I
I I saw some more results compared with
state of J approach so in s separation
Community we have a size Campaign which
is organized by one and and a half years
by by the steering committee which
associated with the S separation
conference which is known IC conference
and for this campaign where the
organizer uh have some common data and
the participant when uh use their aism
to separate the file and and and submit
the results so that the organizer will
evaluate the performance so they give
the Bland data so or other participant
don't know anything and they give back
the Wii and then the result is evaluated
by the organizer and we uh EV
participated in the data of to
2008 actually recently is 2010 already
and we compare with uh five uh four
state of Z acoss which for for instance
Aris come from anti in Japan which is
very well known for S separation and man
come from the Columbia University with
Dan Alis so very famous and isumi also
come from Tokyo University so this all
state of
appro and here I test with the five
microphone spacing data set and here is
what the result we have with three
sources and with two sources compared to
set of Z across yeah so that was the
best number of all the entries you call
the best number yeah yeah I I I compared
to all the number I mean when the 250 MC
it looks like
like the Iraqi method is 3.7 versus your
3.8 it's quite close straight uh here
Iraqi yeah yeah yeah sure I I I I don't
confirm that I'm outform everything I
mean it is really hard and let me also
emphasize that it is with 5 cm spacing
and with more large number of microphone
spacing even at keepy I perform our me
because our meod we need to solve
permutation problem and if you have
large uh microphone distance so you have
many face wrapping so the it can degrade
a lot of performance yeah so that's why
I choose 5
cm yeah but solving your peration is not
the main goal of our appro so these
these are your implementations of their
algorithms or this is what they've
published yeah yeah what you published
and and the data is test and submitted
theirself not mine I mean we all
submitted to to the same uh organizer so
that's ni and actually recently uh we in
20110 I also attend and I I didn't write
result here but let me summarize in
2010 uh the group of uh
entities outperform another one and
there is two other people outperform
this method one from uh EPF of
Switzerland and one is I say but these
two as people use our framework it means
that he use exactly the full R I
proposed here in 2009 but he as more
concern on the source variances so here
uh Source variant V is free right I
don't use any model for V but for those
two appro they as NF model for V and the
oan model for V and they get better
performance so it's usual yeah okay so
so one other question you may have said
this before but like so in all these
cases the number of sources is known
right yeah yeah sure okay okay it's
always specifi yeah for estimating the
number of s is remain challenging I
think but in all these experiments it's
yes it's
known
okay so regarding a question about the
frequency resolution before I test
between the shortterm Fay representation
where uh the bank frequency bandwidth is
linearly equal for all frequency range
and if you apply Erb which is more
acoustically motivated it will provide a
narrower band at the low frequency range
where most s energy lie in and our
result so that uh the Erb will perform
better performance than the softer F
transform why we have this because uh
yeah so difficulty uh of estimating the
motor parameter is that we have a lot of
time frequency overlap between
sources I mean if the sources is really
spare in the time frequency regon it is
easier to estimate the parameter right
but if is really overlap so uh it is
more difficult to estimate mod parameter
but if we use
Erb we have a narrow band at the low
frequency range so we have a less
overlap right yeah that's why it
uh uh out form the shortterm fre
transform and this result is what
published in our ICI paper in
2010 okay that is
briefly and now is for a short time I
move quickly to also a uh good
contribution of the paper is a defining
some probability prior up to now as just
present General framework as the
parameter is estimated
uh in the maximum likelihood S without
knowing anything
right but in practice in many cases for
instance if you look at the speed
enhancement in a car you may know
exactly the position of the driver and
co-driver or in a formal meeting room
the poison of each delegate is fixed it
means that in such situation the G sing
is known so so that you can exploit this
knowledge in order to enhance s
separation so for that motivation we
design the spal location
prior okay let me also consider another
one so up to now I just assume that uh a
app is is is is time invariant but if
you consider the moving sources for
instance if I talk like this I keep
moving or if you consider the rum so
there several rum like he hat and snare
so that the a should not be time
invariant right so in that time uh we
should consider time varying spal poison
of the sources but we can desire some
continuity prior it means that we assume
that it's time varying but it should
have some structure over time so that's
why we also design some spal continuity
prior for that and these two different
prior is published in two different IAS
paper this year
okay or if you look at uh spectral
information of the sources for instance
if you look at Spectrum of the r it is
quite smoothly over time why if you look
at Spectrum of harmonic or piano for
instance it is quite harmonicity and
smooth over frequency
range given that you can also uh desire
some special continuity prior to enforce
the
smoothness over time of frequency Ser so
this is a series of uh prior information
we consider in order to enhance s
separation in specific uh setting where
we know
something okay a bit detail about space
prior so here is the model you uh have
seen before the forine direct plus
review but this model we test with a
large data and we found that it's it
it's quite good in terms of the
approximation for the mean of the spal
coent masses this means that if you have
a lot of poison of sources so the mean
can follow this one but in practice we
it's going vary over the mean right
that's why we can Define some
distribution of a by the inverse reset
prior where the mean of a is defined by
this and we need to estimate or to learn
the variant so that we know the
distribution and we can estimate the
parameter is the maximum L maximum
poster sense right okay uh let me go a
little bit faster and just give a basic
ID and also we get the close form update
in map
s okay and here is some
results is uh here uh I just want to
show that uh we if we know some
knowledge about the geometry setting we
can get the better performance foron
compare to the Bland initialization in a
maximum l s right
okay okay for spal continuity prior we
consider this prior in the context of
musical short
separation where the music
will okay and we also defies some uh
probability distribution a so the mean
at the current time frame we depends on
the value at the previous time frame so
we have a continuity
constraints okay
so now uh I I come back with us uh
experience to to solve some uh
practical uh where our framework is is
shown to to to to provide good
performance from
uh if you look at uh music mixure so it
uh it it can
be uh consider as a mixture of harmonic
component and Progressive component and
R and in the mere Community people try
to separate harmonic component and rum
component in order to perform some other
music information receiver and we apply
our framework with the continuity
prior so we get the results for multi
Chanel harmonic and Progressive sour
separation and we compare this result
with the existing single chn SPS which
is proposed by the group in the
University of
Tokyo okay and here is the results we
get here is the for for example one
music
Mio and soon it will
be
I want to
see okay so here is a harmonic component
we
separate uh here per
component will be
okay if you compare with state of for
perip you will hear
is so do few differences
now yeah because the last question is
yeah I agree for Speed is difficult but
uh yeah I have some cowork with the
group of University of Tokyo where we
try to explore this framework in the
context of Music information reer yeah
so here instead of Z you can hear a lot
of artifact so the rum is much distort
you can you you may not hear the the the
actual r i play
game
might not be the important thing if the
goal is that you're trying to find
features for for Mirror kind of stuff
you might care about Tempo and like you
know which drums are being play when
stuff like that the actual acoustic
artifacts are more if humans are
listening to the output I guess another
question i' have those like so in this
case so how are you so are are you
manually defining what the priors are
for the different types of sources here
are you estimating them from data where
they coming from so for the prior uh
there is only two parameter one is mean
and one is variant so for me it's okay
it's Welly and for variant I manually
choose but I observe that uh the result
is not very sensitive to the two of of
the variant but one is one is Broad yeah
sure you can vary is between 10 or 100
is okay but of course it's okay you you
can learn from froming data sure and the
source is what a regular stereo
recording stere recording yeah stere or
monophonic it's a single Channel yeah
for Senor channnel we separate Source in
each stal uh Channel separated so you
did like you took one of the St channels
and then for
these so this is not a fair compersion I
I would say because I compare the MTI
channel one is a single channel one is
channel one channel so I I I I say it's
not fair but for state of Z approach I I
didn't find any MTI approach because for
for for music s separation most people
people youing the channel and they
exploit uh the the the model for the
special temporal of the sources to to in
order to separate like so yeah I I Tred
to look for for state of that MTI
Channel but I I didn't see the one
okay okay so here is Roy conclusion so
in this work we introduce the
probability space model uh for the
reation and diffuse
sources and we propose the unconcious
parameterization of the spatial
covariant matches which overcomes the
Nan assumption to a certain extent and
which better account for the reation as
shown in the experimental
results we also consider the use of the
local empirical covariant for the
parameterization it's a sigma head of us
which provide additional information and
recently we propos several probabilities
prior which have enhan separation in a
certain context where we know uh some
information
yeah okay uh for the Future Works uh we
can consider the work towards the BL
sour separation explo is a spal location
prior it is very related to the question
before about the fect plus refuse model
and even for this prior we need to know
the mean it means that we need to know
that uh mes and if we can find a way to
estimate the parameter like estimate the
source de way and duration time it is SM
practice and we can consider the use of
the propose framework in another field
of signal processing uh for instance in
Mia that is what we are doing now and
recently I found that there are some
people already use alame work for
instance Hitachi uh togami in Hitachi
use our modeling in their acoustic echo
canellation system and arak key also
combine our approach with the time
frequency masking so to enhance
separation is this sh I 201 paper yeah
okay because these two guys from
industry so they consider the practical
application so uh Soo use the ID but he
do not uh use the same estimation
technique because our is require more
time so so com with their approach and
use the shorter uh yeah faster
estimation parameter yeah and we also
can consider the propos framework in
space audio where we analyze and Rend
ring the spal S yeah
okay and I think that is uh end of my
presentation and here is some references
you can uh f is more questions so thank
you for the ATT thank
you okay thank you very much for the
ATT